cita electoral para los cubanos esta vez
en un referendo para decidir si aceptan
o rechazan el nuevo código de las
familias con medidas progresistas como
el matrimonio igualitario o la
redefinición del concepto de familia
tradicional supondría un avance para la
realidad que viven los miembros de la
comunidad lgtbiq como la del escritor
Antón arrufat histórico activista
puede ser una modificación cuidando de
nuestras vidas el nuevo código de más de
100 páginas también permitiría la
adopción en parejas del mismo sexo o la
gestación subrogada siempre que no sea
cambio de dinero una reforma ampliamente
secundada por el gobierno en medio de la
crisis económica y de suministros de La
Isla
el código de las familias es la
esperanza de miles de personas marcadas
por dolorosas historias de exclusión y
silencio por ellos y por Cuba código sí
los referendos suelen tener una alta
participación de entorno al 90%, pero en
este se espera que sea menor por el
descontento social algo que preocupa a
los analistas y Defensores de Derechos
Humanos el código no tiene nada que ver
con la situación económica que estamos
viviendo el código no tiene que ver con
la inflación y el código no tiene que
ver con la crisis económica el código
tiene que ver con hacer avanzar los
derechos humanos en un país marcado por
la muerte presencia de la iglesia Yo soy
cristiano Tengo otras concepciones estoy
en una mesa electoral fíjate la
responsabilidad que tengo pero no
no acepto esa de ganar el sí Cuba se
convertiría en el noveno país
latinoamericano en legalizar el
matrimonio igualitario a la vanguardia
de muchos de sus vecinos